okay hello I'm Eric shatters I'm from
Mozambique I'm a young global leaders
and I'm here to state have the
importance on access to information
especially I abuses inclusivity for the
poor when you look at em getting out of
poverty one of the fundamental pillars
that exists or that should be there that
people should be informed people should
know what goes on in their lives in the
world they should be included in the
society rather than excluded and if we
don't make provision that news general
information gets to the poor there's
very little difficulty however very
little everybody well is it a lot of
difficulty for them to actually become
included on the general economical
society well when you only look at the
one of the that was questions which is
about education and poverty you'll find
out that in most of the developing
countries one of the things that it's
happening is that and very few children
actual you attending I go to school and
those that do do not get the ability to
practice reading to actually get
informed of what goes on in the world to
become aware of the circumstances that
surround them and therefore I better
equipped with the tools that would allow
them and to fight for their own future
so when you address the issue of poverty
and education it is extremely important
to consider the access to information
the majority of the population in the
poorer communities in the world do not
have access to things like television
newspapers with internet and for example
in a place like Mozambique less than ten
percent of the population has access to
electricity that limits their capacity
to be connected when you look at the the
economical ability most of them can't
afford to buy a television can't afford
to buy a computer will be connected to
the internet when you look at for
example at the readership there's six
million people that can read but I'm
newspapers exist in the formal economy
less than 10,000 so you are targeting
less than point one percent of the
population that can actually afford to
read and write so it is extremely
important that we push on for this
access to information making it widely
available in some information that
should just republic and browse to
become citizens in the global economy
okay that's my that was the date
contribution thank you